bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
actualité la deuxième émission de cette
saison 2006-2007 toujours avec notre
sympathique est excellent le grand
maître des horloges bonjour là bonjour
stéphane bonjour à tous non merci pour
ses compliments
alors aujourd'hui on va parler du
phénomène de cette rentrée du grand
grand rendez-vous de cette rentrée le
championnat du monde unifié en
impression d'être un petit peu à la boxe
il ya deux champions du moins
actuellement on peut dire le vainqueur
de du match contre kasparov et honni et
des diagonales y était en 2000 kramnik
avait battu kasparov
il va s'affirmer il a confirmé ensuite
contre peter l'écho confirmé quand peter
les cours et face donc aux champions du
monde en titre de la fidh donc le
champion de la fédération sans champions
elle qui est veselin topalov et qui est
numéro un mondial numéro un mondial au
classement elo mesquine topalov
effectivement l'homme de l'année 2005
voire de l'année 2010 ils gagnent tous
les tournois il est spectaculaire
très impressionnant y gagnent toutes les
parties de l'île en perd beaucoup
alors c'est ça la différence va y avoir
une très belle opposition de style entre
wesseling topalov qui considère que la
défaite ça fait partie du jeu et que
l'on doit perdre des partis pour vous
digne et plus et vladimir kramnik
considère qu'on doit jamais perdre et
gagner une partie temps là on peut dire
aussi insouciant se référer un peu
l'histoire parce que là on est lassé
c'est un peu un rendez vous historique
on retrouve la lignée des 14 champions
du monde jusqu'à chronique
on peut dire que kramnik c'est un peu le
petrossian moderne sert petrossian
champion du monde des années 60 qui
perdait jamais et qu'ils disent est ce
le vainqueur ce sera celui qui perdra
pas est plutôt topalov qui plutôt dans
la lignée je dirais d'un ali qui soudain
ou d'un oudin kasparov c'est-à-dire un
attaquant qui veut gagner à tout prix
mouais mais je crois que total of on a
une nouvelle génération de
un nouveau style de joueur qui est une
sorte de petit copain sorte de de fous
furieux qui va chercher le point d'aller
chercher le micro avantage tout le temps
il ne fait jamais nulle
ils jouent toutes ces parties à fond
mais vraiment à fond et d'une créativité
incroyable
il joue avec les pions avec les pièces l
attaque très bon aperture d'ouverture eu
quatre des cats il joue la nage dorff
avec les noirs toute la partie laissait
gagner des lacs et noir y laisser gagner
tout le temps il sait gagner tout le
temps c'est vrai mais non on peut dire
aussi son style et à l'énergie c'est un
vrai sport pour lui sert pour topalov
les échecs c'est un sport c'est à dire
que même si j'ai pas pris l'avantagé
tout de suite à l'ouverture c'est pas
grave je vais lutter jusqu'au bout pour
essayer de gagner
quitte à jouer sur la fatigue dans mon
adversaire en fait c'est juste topalov
en fin de tournoi est toujours le
dernier le dernier survivant
c'est à dire qu'il ya plus pluie qui
joue à la fin du tournoi tous les autres
sont complètement cuits ils font leur
petit tenus d'y jouer partie tranquille
topalov mais il est là et en général il
finit par 3 sur 3 4 sur 4 et au palace a
réalisé une performance exceptionnelle
du jamais vu dans l'histoire d'un échec
aux championnats du monde fis dès qu'il
a gagné il a commencé par six et demi
sur 7 contre eux l'élite mondiale
oui si c'est ni sur cet été 6 victoires
1 nul contre allende où ils étaient
gagnants merci énorme ah oui dans les
topaloff est un joueur exceptionnel et
maintenant chronique
est-ce qu'il faut mentionner c'est tu
l'a jamais perdu deux matches si si il a
perdu un match face à shirov face à
chekhov à barcelone mais c'était oui
d'ailleurs lieu d'histoire jean fabbri
devait jouer kasparov et finale s'est
cramé cramique à jouer et qui a bien
fait puisqu'il a battu kramnik est sans
doute le meilleur joueur du match du
moment et topalov et sans discussion le
meilleur joueur de tournoi voilà c'est
ça le problème donc c'est pas la même
chose parce que c'est après un tournoi
on peut gagner un tournoi sans forcément
pouvoir capable de battre un joueur en
particulier de ce tournoi un match en
match et à des stratégies différentes
qui arrivent via notamment la
préparation dans les ouvertures qui
devient complètement différente puisque
pour un tournoi on prépare plusieurs
ouvertures contre plusieurs adversaires
alors qu'en match on va jouer la même
ouverture dix fois de suite
donc là il ya une équipe derrière
travnik pour ça il
le top j'ai des joueurs qui sont
habitués à travers les ouvertures les
mêmes positions les choses qui se répète
alors que top alors foncez pas puisque
topaloff est très peu expérimenté un
match donc c'est justement la chance de
vladimir kramnik c'est son expérience
des matches sont calmes bon évidemment
sa compréhension du jeu mais quand même
la chronique cette céramique et
peut-être pas nui à angoulême je crois
qu'il y ait encore il est quatrième les
4ème et et et encore une fois le chum
n'a pas toujours été numéro un sur la
liste exemple petrossian mes exemples
aussi peut-être est-ce parce qu'il était
champion du monde alors que fisher était
devant
veillez beaucoup d'exemples beaucoup
d'exemples je ne connais pas très bien
mais disons que groupe le prestigieux
classement elo il n'existe que depuis
1977 n'a pas eu beaucoup depuis depuis
les fichiers
karpov kasparov et kasparov a été
champion du monde alors qu'il était au
départ une version inférieure semé de
kharkov
par contre à la fin quand il avait
dépassé mais bon ça s'est joué à très
peu de choses et kramnik a battu
kasparov alors qu'il était au classement
un peu un peu en dessous mais comme quoi
il ya vraiment une subtilité de tournon
anac
alors on peut dire aussi que cette
opposition tournant match on revient à
une polémique qu'avait lieu dans les
années 60 parce que bobby fischer qui
était déjà considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde de 1966 n'a
pas dû attendre 1512 avons pouvoir
cherche à faire son match il a il avait
arrêté je crois qu'il avait fait un tour
l'un des candidats est un très jeune a
15 ans en 1958 il me semble et ensuite
il a arrêté de faire les tournois en dix
ans mais je peux pas jouer les tournois
c'est pas intéressant enfin sepa sepa
fair play et pour moi puisque je me
retrouve seul américain à jouer dans un
tournoi où il ya des russes ils font des
nuls entre facile pour passe re est
contre moi ils jouent à fond alors là
c'était comme c'est un mélange de beurre
enfin c'est un peu de la paranoïa
même si c'est un peu vrai mais de toute
façon ça change pas
enfin bon c'est pas très grave non plus
respecté n'empêche que on peut dire que
fisher a dû attendre que les matchs
seront mis en place
et quand les matches étaient en place il
a joué 6 0 6 1 et 6 2 ensuite battu
spassky alors qu'un tournoi c'était très
dur pour lui mais pour revenir à ce
qu'indique topalov ça va vraiment être
un match exceptionnel
c'est vraiment un match passionnant et
les pronostics j'ai pas la moindre idée
de ce que ça donne à voir qu'est ce que
ça peut toucher suis un énorme fan de
topalov j'adore son style mais je suis
pas sûr qu'il va gagner ce match enfin c
amy ton talent enfin le friant vous la
dirai qu'on vit tous les deux ans et
puis ce qu'un gène et nous avait
fortement impressionné lors de son match
contre kasparov
environnement sa défense berlinoise
sorti d'on ne sait où et qui a mis en
place par au feu dans une position
extrêmement critique
il n'a pas réussi à passer cette défense
de l'animal et il n'avait pas du tout
prévu ça il n'a pas réussi à trouver la
solution dans le laps de temps du match
nous cramique est peut-être un très
faible psychologue et peut-être un très
grand préparateur de match il va
peut-être trouvé la faiblesse de topalov
et ça c'est le deuxième le deuxième
concours de pronostics c'est trouver les
ouvertures que vladimir kramnik va jouer
oui parce que il peut nous sortir encore
peut-être un vieux truc alors il ya un
problème c'est au palais qui jouent des
4 et aux quatre parfaitement mes 2 duo
nantais sport quand il arrive dans un
match il a comme son coût compétitif le
coup sûr l'église s'y prépare une
probablement top alors ça sera le cas
aussi mais topalov peut switcher de 4 à
d4 il le fait dans toutes les parties
qui changent à chaque fois en plusieurs
cycles le match est vraiment différente
tournant dans la mesure où justement en
générant près par une arme et il faut
passer avec cette arme là et si si on
passe pas
c'est quasiment foutu en fait parce que
on a essayé exclusivement sur un axe
faibles de l'adversaire sur lequel on
nous dit on est très fort c'est très
difficile avec les noirs on dit qu'il
faut avoir au moins deux ouvertures
c'est à dire une ouverture on va jouer
et si ça passe pas eh bien on passera à
la deuxième l'ouverture de secours
pendant qu'on serait en train de réparer
la première oui mais alors le problème
c'est qu'avec un joueur comme topalov
dans trois parties on peut se retrouve
avec les deux ouvertures car vous posez
oui et là bas là c'est fini quoi ça va
être passionnant la soldate
ça va être très intéressant et donc le
diagonal va va suivre évidemment cette
halle avec attention c'est ce choc
l'avion avec attention toutes les
parties seront commentés sur des modèles
on aura donc quasiment et moi je crois
de match dont moins de trois semaines
puisqu'il ya douze parties prévues bon
évidemment ça peut arriver avant
victoire par exemple 7 0 de ses pages au
total c'est possible vous êtes 02
kramnik donc sept parties peuvent
suffire mais
sinon donc à partir du 30 septembre
des émissions régulières de diagonale
disponible en téléchargement avec
chacune des parties commentées de
champion de monde qui est le rendez-vous
non seulement de cette année mais des
six dernières années puisque ça fait six
ans qu'on attend un successeur à kramnik
qui a battu kasparov qui lui même a
battu celui qui a battu et c'est juste
la steinitz en 1886 donc ça remonte loin
je pense est une chaîne qui est
difficile d'ignorer ou deux cas c'est
bien entendu c'est vrai qu'il ya eu avec
14 champion du monde en plus de 100 ans
donc effectivement c'est une belle
tradition alors je crois qu'on a des
photos des photos non on a une vidéo
d'eux m'a dit mercredi justement dans
son match contre kasparov
bientôt le découvrir
oui sur le ralenti superbe superbes
plans d'un joueur
tempête sous un tram on avait pas le
titre de cette photo ouais tempête sous
un crâne et tempête sous un crâne seule
elle est là qu est ce qu on peut avoir
un plan sur le fauteuil de kasparov au
revoir s'il n'est pas derrière ça
devrait être
c'est possible on est pas des régionales
fauteuil est on
apparemment on a le fauteuil médiévale
de kasparov g nicolas cravic ça c'est un
beau plan pratique très concentré voyez
les yeux qui bouge alors sur internet on
les voit probablement pas mais cram
nikki est à l'affût d'une solution de
calcul très vite ses joueurs je crois
qu'ils calculent vraiment très vite à
eux ils calculent extrêmement vite
donc ils peuvent concentrer leur
attention non pas sur le calcul mais
justement sur les considérations
générales positionnelle qui sont les
plus importantes et donc ils sont pas
distraire par les variantes annexes
voilà donc dix passages intéressants où
le ciel de kasparov était vide peut-être
un signe oui
garry kasparov kibaki cela fait beaucoup
pour un match d'ailleurs les deux
joueurs se lève beaucoup en général
quand ils ont fini joué leur coup ils
sont donc tu parle ainsi d'un niveau de
10 est de la place oui c'est de la place
oui oui le fauteuil en plus non photo y
remédier alors à noter que pour ceux qui
suivraient diagonale un peu pour la
première fois qu'est devenu kasparov à m
kasparov s'est retiré il a pris sa
retraite
même si normalement il fait un petit
match d'exhibition parce qu'il a dit
qu'il restait disponible pour des
matches exhibition il a arrêté la
compétition internationale puisqu'il se
dédit maintenant la politique et il veut
ça ne rend projet restaurer lui
démocratie en russie ont vaillamment et
débouté vladimir poutine voilà le but
que s'est fixé kasparov
toujours à la recherche de notre
challenge est là c'est le cerveau tchad
m est très élevé alors lui souhaite
bonne chance
c'est passionnant a besoin oui donc mais
en tout cas il est actif sur ce terrain
là
l'air de vouloir aller au bout de sa
démarche dont kasparov reste quand même
un petit peu avec un petit oeil quand
même puisqu'il continue a commenté plus
ou moins ce qui se passe mais il est
clairement retirer d'ailleurs il a fait
tout petit tournant qu'il a fait une
exhibition il avait le temps de
l'anniversaire de victor knight on
habite oui il a fait premier ex-aequo
avec art voilà les cartes peuvent donc
pour ça c'est si simple pour le résultat
c'est un des résultats puisque pour lui
puisque carpates a longtemps qu'il avait
des bas c'est karpov qui quand même le
jour cela dit la fed est très très belle
partie si vous avez l'occasion de les
regarder quand ils gagnent kasparov
s'est quand même où il reste il reste un
gros show est du propre prêt à voir ce
que ça donne c'est au niveau politique
je sais pas alors donc la lumière
kramnik qui est le champion du monde
qu'on dit classique
lundi je parlais tout à l'heure il ya 14
champions du monde classique depuis que
le titre de champion du monde est
reconnu comme officiel depuis 1886
williams tennis pour me championne du
monde officiel il ya eu en publicité
peut-être il ya eu emmanuelle nas caire
ensuite il ya eu aussi à raul capablanca
ensuite quitté cuba ensuite à franco
russe c'était un liquide petit intermède
avec max hoff en hollande et qui a tenu
deux ans ensuite les kinés mort afin a
repris son titre éléments afin de la
guerre et devient tournoi justement pour
désigner le successeur
ça a été bonne fini qu ils râlent
bonnefis nick grand théoricien russe
ella alors tous les russes ont gagné
ensuite il
mais quel talent pour un an le temps que
vos micros prennent ce type
ensuite m smith l'ofs un homme aussi le
temps que bobigny qu'on reprenne son
titre petrossian en fait qui l'a débouté
totalement votre unique qui lui reste
est championne pendant six ans jusqu'en
1969 où boris spassky a pris la relève
bobby fischer en 1972 donc le grand
bobby fischer qui reste peut-être
l'étoile filante la plus la plus
fantastique très spectaculaire oui
énormément
seul américain à avoir jamais conquis le
titre il a seul le sol américain
mais depuis que les russes ont pris
titre en fait et après donc bisous tout
le monde connaît peut-être ça enfin
c'est un peu plus proche de nous en tout
cas kharkov de 75 à 85 kasparov de 85 en
2001 des plus long règne du jeu d'échecs
avec celui de la sq avait duré 20 ans
d'ailleurs quasiment fait dit lui-même
dit que son règne devrait jusqu'à l'an
2000 alors qu'il avait prévu sa fin oui
tout à fait et il perd donc face à
kramnik qui depuis a défendu sans titre
une seule fois face habitants les coûts
problème puisque en fait depuis 1993 il
ya eu une scission qui fait que la fille
des roues connaissait un autre titre
mais qui a été beaucoup plus galvaudé
puisque été gagné par des joueurs je
dirais de seconde zone est bien le fils
avait une coupe du monde en fait d'abord
il ya eu quelques matches il ya eu la
pca également qui avait organisé un
circuit de tournois et la fidl je sais
pas de quand date le premier champion du
monde fidèle avait depuis 93 en fait
karpov contre tim and non je pensais
plutôt à la coupe du monde avait la
coupe du roi noir mais si blagnac où il
ya eu un califat mais je crois c'est
venu assez tard en fait ça dû venir en
99 il me semble voilà 99
donc cette heure la spéculation et donc
c'est là que kalichman à gagner oui
ensuite il ya eu notre ami le problème
c'est qu'on s'en rappelle plus sociale
cazères pas rencontré une quinzaine
janov être également c'était le souk
il ya eu à tarnos il ya eu alors qu en
fait on a eu tous les ans alors qu'on
avait l'habitude d'avoir plus de monde
pour au moins 3 4 ans le mort cinq ans
et d'ailleurs on a par anand
mais ces sont des joueurs qui oscillé
entre la 30e et 40e place mondiale
s'était pas rendue crédible
le système était un peu trop aléatoire
exactement c'était des matchs cours de
partie tout peut arriver quand même
parce que même le 30e joueur mondial il
est quand même là pour il peut les
déstabiliser sur deux parties n'importe
quel choix d'ailleurs que les angels a
fait 28 topalov lagana fois dans cette
scission a créé ce problème donc jeu
d'échecs qui maintenant va être résolue
à la fin de ce mois septembre donc le
match que tout le monde attend alors on
va passer tout de suite on reviendra
après sur la ceni topalov facile tout de
suite sur une analyse d'une partie de
vladimir kramnik une partie d'ailleurs
c'est passé il signe donc on savait pas
celle ci
donc non plus alors à peut-être pour
revenir sur mon jeu j'aime tout
simplement revenir sur la partie que je
cherche donc c'est une partie et loi
c'est une partie chroniques contre
bruzzone crown petone qui a eu lieu aux
olympiades
nous comptons lympia de turin cette
année donc bruzzone c'est un joueur
besoin d dominguez sont des joueurs
cubain donc qui qui joue très bien des
jeunes experts en défense très très bon
défenseur très très bon joueur qui
calcule très vite et très bien et
vladimir kramnik donc dans le match
russie
mais bon ça me revient pas à cuba dans
le match russie cuba aux olympiades
d'échecs de vladimir kramnik avec les
pièces blanches qui va nous faire une
partie un peu l'opposition de son style
habituel puisque le son style habituel
c'est quand même sérieux on prend la
paire de fou petit avantage en finale
transformation 45e coup voilà à l'usure
mais ici il a fait une très très belle
partie d' attaque donc cette partie et
qu'un très intéressante parce qu'on va
voir aussi une partie des tailles de
topalov évidemment puisqu'elle que ça
donc ici nous allons regarder cette
partie de plaisir cramique contre reason
alors c'est parti c'est parti cavalier
f3 beaucoup aux favoris de vladimir
kramnik il joue très rarement et 4 g
unique parce que
il a essayé bien sûr il ya des très
mauvais résultats donc il a abandonné
l'idée de jouer aux quatre ils
conservent les ouvertures du plan table
des cinq des quatre dons classiques un
début du pion dame mais pas grand chose
à dire pour l'instant si ses cadres
alors ces quatre coups classiques d'un
des millions d'âmes aller loin c'est
tout à fait normal c'est très très
logique
cette avance ses pions puisqu'on dit
qu'il faut mettre les pièces derrière
donc maintenant on prépare la sortie du
cabinet en c3 avec l'option qui sera pas
bloquée en c2 ensuite le plan standard
ses terres ce qui risque d'arriver quand
les noirs vont jouer sur une surface
blanche à l'exception des cinq est bien
c'est qu'on va préparer d'avancé eu 4
pour prendre le centre donc ça grosso
modo c'est ce qui risque de se passer
maintenant la théorie moderne stéphane
est tellement compliqué tellement 38
tellement avancé qu' on en a presque
oublié que l'idée des blancs s'étaient
joués 4 tellement il ya deux variantes
théorique compliqué qui délient un peu
de cette stratégie de base donc ici
voilà l'idée c4c 6 ça c'est la défense
slave
donc l'idée s'est défendu pierre des
cinq de reprendre avec le pion si jamais
les blancs prennent donc stabiliser le
centre en même temps on n'a pas joué le
site à la place de ces six qui aurait
été un grand vide âme parce qu'on veut
conserver l'option du fou s'est vite qui
peut encore sortir dans sap ne veut pas
l'enfermer voilà ce serait mauvais goût
affirmé anne ont alors deux
non c'est un jouet aussi ça la place de
ses fils et le candidat mme ouimet
l'ouverture dans les deux langues permet
une fois qu'on a joué ces six voilà être
le deuxième pion les deux écrans aussi
ce serait une erreur
c'est la somme islam alors c'est il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de théories fans tout
est possible à cet effet s'il s'agit
quand même bien de fou derrière la somme
islam hors ue y avait je connaissais
même pas la simulation de systèmes de
mayran très très bien connu stéphane et
c'est très solidement en fait l'idée
générale c'est que les noirs conservent
leur centre ils ont fait un centre
solides ils peuvent jouer à peu près
n'importe quoi ils ont pas de faiblesses
ils n'ont pas de retard de développement
simplement ils ont un peu le truc c'est
que si les blagues les blancs prépare le
4 avec un petit avantage qui risque
d'arriver maintenant évidemment c'est
très compliqué calé ces trois là slave
normal donc ici plusieurs possibilités
qu'on peut noter qu'avec le pion ses
cartes et en pisé loin une chance et 4
est un prix c'est la deuxième idée de
ses six c'est que on prépare à l'avancé
des saints pour soutenir l'option ses
gardes au cas où on prendrait d'accord
ce qu'est ce qui lie heures aurait pu
arriver ici des trois grands coups tian
français quatre sont preneurs possible
mais ça laisse ça laisse le centre aux
blancs ces salles des avantages
je peux vous montrer une petite le début
de variante 1 parce qu'on va pas on
n'est pas là pour donner 1 200 sur les
ouvertures en france les quatre on joue
à quatre pour éviter l'avancée des cinq
des noirs avec l'idée ensuite deux camps
celui qu'on a eu 3 et foot français les
quatre mois et donc on se retrouve avec
deux pions au centre contre un seul
c'est à dire un petit avantage
symbolique que 3 ou même des fois de 4,8
me la variante principal c'est 5 pour
empêcher juste avec un débat débattent
et brillant mais c'est une ouverture sur
un choix en fait c'est des possibilités
donc ici le donc le coup on vient
regarder dépensé cadre le coup très à la
mode ces assisses pour les
les fanas d'ouverture théorique qui est
très compliqué l'idée c'est encore de
renom à ses pions en france et 4 de
garder l'option de sortir le fou et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle le slave à 6 mais
ici brothers n'a joué la semi slave
stéphane déjouer aussi donc maintenant
possibilité pour les blancs de jouer
deux ou trois petits coups qui rentre
dans des énormes partie de kasparov et
karpov et karpov et kasparov les enjeux
étaient de couleur ce matin là on peut
pas trop s'appesantir non plus sur une
personne puisqu'on a deux parties à voir
aujourd'hui puisqu'on verra aussi celle
de topalov fou g5 ici le coût normal le
la bande variantes ont plus le cavalier
cavale et b17 secoué ça s'appelle la
cambridge au sprint
c'est une ouverture anglaise le 3 donc
là si tout va bien pour les blancs ils
ont réussi à sortir leur fou maintenant
ils vont préparer l'avancé aux 4 donc ça
va être fou t3 petit rock tenn ces deux
dames 2 et préparer le coup autres
organes dana 5 c'est le coût qui
caractérise bien la cambridge ring on
profite que le fou de cases noires
soient passés derrière le pion c'est là
qu'elle va te veux plus revenir pour
essayer de poser des petits problèmes
avec ce petit clouage dame fou du roi
puis on prend des cinq c'est le couple
négatif c'est il ya d'autres
possibilités sont plus tranquilles
notamment le coup quel est des deux mais
bien trois des cinq c'est le coup show
qu'elle prend des salles est simple
n'hésite pas à jouer c'est cool non là
donc là on est dans le clouage c'était
en voie de la menace tout de suite quel
écran cavaliers avec la dame qui vient
reprendre
oui il faut des formes qui perdrait un
pion d'un des deux d'amener de fougue et
4 on est complètement dans l'idée de la
campagne de ce ring maintenant avantage
blanc sur le long terme grâce au duo
depuis ans un trou oui deux contre un
mais tout de suite avec un problème
problème menace qu il est prince
accablées prendre puis on prend vous
prend et la dame et père accusé de l'aca
serait très très grave donc tour c'est
un faux vous faut se défendre
heureusement pour la tour info free
prévoit la bouche et les voilà
maintenant h6 attaque un peu fou dont ça
c'est du détail noufou 124 c'est la
seule case mais des fois c'est les
petits détails qui font la différence à
l'actif l'indifférence a dû être
calculée par dow jones
petit rock maintenant la dynamique de
sacrifiable mais le clouage est très
désagréable
le plus âgé très désagréable il y avait
un grand court principal c'était de
jouer aux quatre maintenant mais leur
offre aussi une autre une langue qui
conduit à la nulle part c'est pourquoi
leur donner le parti laurent frayssinet
laurent frayssinet les trouver oui oui
c'est la partie il y aussi le dorfman
quand laurent frayssinet au championnat
de france
ah bon je ne sais pas il a trouvé un way
donc il fallait tourner en noir mais une
force et nous forcer finale mais c'est
théorique donc c'est un rapace en plus
personne ne joue aux cartes grâce à
fasciner une grasse matinée à cause des
frais signer mais dans le monde entier
voyait tout à fait d'accord donc c'est
une ouverture
c'est ce qu'on appelle il est donc il
est donc finalement il est créateur
d'une quasiment d'une réfutation en fait
à dion l'invitation du cou ou quatre qui
avant était considéré comme le meilleur
à 3 donc là on va voir on attaque le fou
alors une erreur serait de prendre le
cavalier avec lecavalier
oui tout à fait stéphane gavelle prend
cavaliers ne serait pas acceptable à
cause de pions prends tu apprends fou la
dame est une fois que la dame a répondu
on prend le cavalier ça fait deux pièces
exactement
et là c'est pas bon donc sur un très bon
partir avec le fou ça serait mauvais
également puisque maintenant il y aurait
ce qui avait franchi la ligne
oui oui un petit avantage blanc par
exemple n'ont plus que la cette crise
accessible donc parti avec le fou c'est
pas excellent il faut relever le défi
fou prend ces trois qui on prend
obligatoirement on dit on dit souvent
que la meilleure réputation de
sacrifices
la fête c'est accepter d'apprendre qu'on
sait c'est le sacrifice il est là
vladimir kramnik à un changement
maintenant un pion à passer pour les
draps qu'est-ce qu'il en compensation
stéphane et bien il a le centre mobile
puissant qui va avancer
oui et d'ailleurs d'affaires de fouet la
paire de fonds notamment les cases
noires se fout là peut se révéler
énormissime avec les 6,7 et toutes les
quatre mois donc voilà l'idée de ce
sacrifice d'options position tendu on
commence par quatre cavaliers le set
on va dérouler fou détroit développement
normal on sent que ça commence à devenir
agressif vers le roi noir donc sauf à
devenir très très chaud ce fruit de
cases blanches peut lorgner vers le roi
noir qui avait g6 voilà il se prémunit
bruzzone hilali sens il semble dangereux
sur son roi donc ils ramènent et qu'il
est prêt de son roi fou g3 est ici la
menace de la dynamique celle de 5,5
suivi 2009 conditionnelle h5
oui et puis on chasse le dernier validé
a pris deux défenseurs et puis la dame
elle passe et seimat
oui c'est ça va très très vite on va
nettoyer avoir démâté après des jambes
donc fait au sein qui fait bloquer le
centre
voilà rosen bloc i bloc petit rock alors
variantes pour experts on va aller très
vite été fermé parce que le temps presse
sur h41 est bien le seul coup qui peut
sauver la partie s'est tu comprends dès
4 h 5 et petites astuces je montre parce
que c'est assez joli ont ajouté les c5
qui menace d'un grand tour c'est un
hacker prend des trois échecs
donc si vous voulez en savoir plus eh
bien regardez par vous même parce que
c'est très compliqué ici et ça sort un
peu du cadre mais simplement le coach 4
est réfutée par points de rang des
quartiers noirs carte était très fort
d'accord un petit rôle de chroniques
tout rebit de monzon normal
tours est là on va voir que kramnik ne
s'emballe pas oui il n'est pas là avec
son tournoi maintenant et les centristes
y sont développés la et xerox tout
lesquels sont sortis donc on sent que
maintenant ça va passer aux choses
sérieuses alors c'est ça qui est sympa
damas cinq de bronze aux indices dix
jours amènent madame parce que là je
sais pas trop ce qu'elle faisait en
valeur mais c'est bon pour le voleur a
mené au par là un des 8 et pousse ses
pions à et pousser les pions un pur pour
créer une diversion pour empêcher les
blancs d'oeufs de créer des menaces du
côté roy dmb 2 mt 8
et ici stéphane sait vraiment où on sait
plus quoi faire pour les dynamiques donc
il faut réfléchir
quelle est la pièce que je peux
améliorer alors on peut noter
effectivement que le fou ici le fou des
trois maintenant pour l'histoire est
bien bloquée et peut-être que ce four
pourrait se libérer sur la grande
diagonale hm2f sept exactement voilà
l'idée voilà une belle diagonale pour un
fou avec des raisonnements simple on
arrive à trouver les coûts des champions
il a joué tout bien l'année mercredi
il améliore sa dernière pièce qui était
pas encore dans l'action à 5 y avait
encore le tour c'est aussi la manière
aussi a mis la main sur la colonne des
gens vis-à-vis de la dame il dit à la
tour ici et pas moi on aime beaucoup la
position blanche avec le centre
évidemment les noirs en échange on ce
fameux thé au passé et oui et surtout
mais en fait on sait pas encore comment
les blancs vont conclure un mois édition
pour l'instant il immobilise un peu les
noirs enfin on sent qu'on a eue le pion
à vii est très faible loin vraie
déception la il doit y avoir des
sacrifices ils peuvent à peine chose il
veut le faire très attention
en fait le gros problème pour les noirs
dans cette position c'est qu'ils peuvent
pas bouger le cavaly 17 qui devrait
sortir le fossé vite parce que le pion
aux 5 est attaqué trois fois donc il
emprunte sur ce pion aux cinq dames 7
ils peuvent pas le défendre équipe 6 et
peuvent pas jouer c'est bien sûr pour
l'instant il ya toujours ça et si snow
coup qu'on a pas envie d'uriner alors
dams est peu préparés roi bouger et 6
peut-être possible venir car nick fait
dames c'est un un coup mystérieux
mystérieux tour à cinq coups latéral
puisque l'eurozone a compris qu'il
pourrait jamais ramené sept jours par
ici parce que le fournisseur termes
d'accords dam des deux on sait pas ce
que veut faire le numéro chronique
en tout cas il a aussi provoqué une
faute de besogne puisque vos hommes
craquent et joue plus on prend des
cadres petits tracas bhl petit encore
s'il craque un peu la hesse qui menaçait
tout
c'est probablement pas comme menacé de
prendre 5 pour rentrer pas sûr on sait
pas mais en tout cas il faudra laisser
faut pas ouvrir ce centre est évident
que ce pion 5 tonnes et les blancs la
distance mais alors attention parce
qu'en fait tu es demeurer devenir
chronique et prix du cavalier mais bon
on se dit peut-être ces boues mais ils
n'ont toujours pas c'est toujours pas
bon ici on voit la taille de vladimir
transitent toutes les pièces bien placé
c'est en train de se déplier il ya un
cavalier kasparov et l'eau est un
guerrier qui arrive je les cavaliers
kasparov et le fameux cabaye est celle
où kasparov à 10 blessés - coeur f5 pour
moi savons action joliette 5 et qui
décrit les des six là le pion à vii qui
va sauter donc gros problème pour
empêcher ce cavalier d'aller au f5
il faut soit joué un coup de cavaliers
pour maintenir le niveau 5 pour libérer
le fou oui qui vient s'enquérir des
trains coûte outaouais l'anjou et f4
maintenant donc si on repart en 17
il ya cavaliers la rive ouais au point
d'obliger des langes et 4 on attend le
coup très fort c'est eux 5 et là on va
s'apercevoir ces deux options vont
avancer
la suite c'est 56 les deux tours
derrière les cases blanches et les cases
noires à lacets un massacre c'est un
massacre
c'est un massacre donc ici il peut pas
bouger ce cavalier et ce même s'il va
ailleurs avec sens qu'elle va faire
grand chose
déjà là bas donc il a joué mc5 d'ozone
et là c'est arrivé a déjà tout de suite
s'est terminée en voyant comment
vladimir kramnik va réussir à sortir ses
pièces jeu pousser cette attaque
donc ça c'est le numéro un petit coup
qui connaissent attaque l'acteur que
faire voilà on vire la tour qui était
pas si ma place et donc la tower à 8
et maintenant la combinaison faites vous
là bas c'est la loi pas facile l'idée
est de savoir ce qu'on fait parce qu'on
a pas on n'a plus d'objectif d'options
encore une attaque éclair ya le fameux
effectivement soutien f7 qui est faible
et on peut noter que
et en plus oui oui qui a pas beaucoup de
15 après un coup un coût possible
sortait f4 éventuellement compositionnel
il aurait pu poursuivre précisément mis
là où on voit les lois que bataille
finale cabaye f5
imaginons un peu on peut imaginer des
choses qui arrivent c'est ben voilà et
tout de suite
tout de suite on peut jouer à l'aider si
ce peut être par exemple déjà augmenté
faisant une pression énorme sur le don
qui si maintenant il ya une idée est
simple puisqu'on voit que la dame a
cloué le chef de l'anc et plus de 4 ha
oui d'accord donc on arrive à
s'installer là
la menace est faux aussi ce qu'on dise
que les placements elle recense aperçu
et faut faire attention il faut être
très très très attentionné tout à fait
position il faut faire attention donc
faux prince est celle où les chaînes à
profit ce sacrifice obligé d'accepter
c'est là qu'on voit que voulait venir à
nick est pas un joueur de défense note
franchement on en croit prend à vii
obligatoire taf et damas deux à ça alors
ça c'est les échecs qui font très mal
parce que on peut pas mettre aucune
pièce mais sur son coulis partir mais on
peut partir d'un simple je leur dois
partir ça parce qu'on peut pas aller sur
cette case blanche puisque la dame à
l'échec
il faut des célébrités des races et donc
jamais j'étais allé loin il peut pas un
il peut rien interposés madame manon
latour ya pas d'alliés
ici point fr donc il faut jouer trois
fuites voilà elle avait lui aussi sur
cette fourchette oui on chez trois dames
avec lequel il se trouve il faut prendre
il faut prendre
et d'après d'un prendre c'est terminé
ici il ya plus de défense puisque de la
menace et tournefeuille des six échecs
soyez fous des six échecs yagan adam
diadème pranger this gagné une pièce et
il ya toujours trois tours et francs les
nanas s'éteignit natale alors qu'est ce
qu'un jeune a trouvé cavaliers au 7 mai
après tours 3 ces désespérés comme on
peut le voir là pour habiter poussé vite
sont restés hors jeu toute la partie il
a trouvé roi 8 encore aux reason pour
tenir tout rêve trois menaces danneels
est mat mes fromages 5,6 à lui a gagné
et soudée 6 maintenant c'est fini on
peut plus défendre le cabillaud 7 seimat
et donc on respire les potable la
stratégie de vladimir kramnik qu'il adam
chesser je suis pas si sûr d'alger c'est
un objet 5 et bien stéphane plusieurs
possibilités sodome j'ai servi notamment
et bientôt elle s'est tout simplement à
l'air de gagner oui tout à fait
effectivement tout à fait et se
terminent le cavalier 7 n'a plus de
défense un peu plus défendu il ya trois
pièces qu'ils attaquent isle adam
suffira pas aux menaces tout reprend
suivi du mat
ils s'étaient semble terminée c'est une
grosse partie de la dynamique et comme
on voit dans la position finale c'est
vrai que cette position fait plaisir à
voir pour les blancs toutes les pièces
sont actives on a une pièce de moins
mais la position du roi est détruite et
les crânes beaucoup ce genre de position
ça où il a joué placer rouleau
compresseur il sait ce qui c'est comme
ça qu'il a gagné contre kasparov si on
se rappelle bien les parties qu'il a
gagné c'était micro avantage mais
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
bout ah ça oui c'est plus c'est pas tout
à fait typique du style de chronique
c'est typique du style de belles parties
de chroniques
il en fait souvent plus n'est pas
beaucoup ce qui fait plus souvent c'est
effectivement les petits avantages qui
se développent et ainsi de suite
nous voilà notre premier premier joueur
j'en redemande en titre blagnac a mis la
lumière kramnik alors on va passer
maintenant évidemment la présentation de
ce line topalov donc on peut pas dire le
challenger parce qu'il est aussi les
grands championnats
il est considéré comme le champion du
monde mais on doit amener les fans
envoie l'image est nette apal offre un
café mais peut-être plus que les autres
je dirais topalov la légitimité parce
qu'il est numéro 1 mondial sur la liste
du classement c'est juste maintenant il
n'a pas gagné un match à gagner un
tournoi et ça ça quand même ça apporte
la tradition qui dure depuis un siècle
même plus d'un siècle depuis 1886 on
lundi donc un siècle
cent vingt ans exactement l oui ça va
faire ça en même temps donc c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose et c'est vrai
que tu en parles tu n'as pas
l'expérience des matches topalov police
lors ces matches là on voit ici dans un
tournoi effectivement contre notre
etienne bacrot nationale et ce à
souffrir à sofia il avait les blancs
dans cette partie c'est une slave avec à
6 on en a parlé tout à l'heure
très très belles parties de topalov il
avait il a fait gagner une victoire très
belle contre etienne bacrot donc
effectivement voyons peut-être la suite
alors avant qu'on passe la suite oui je
voulais juste chercher voilà j'ai juste
parce que le contrôler la machine
je voulais juste voir voilà on peut
rencontrer
maintenant je voulais juste montrer le
résultat du temps à de sofia justement
où on voit des skins topalov will et
gagner devant le revenant calmes ce film
qui avait été un peu à la retraite il
fait une super grosse performance ce
tournoi même s'il a perdu deux fois
contre topaloff est ou pas l'offre qui
étaient partis mais alors très très
bonne idée d'avoir dû deux défaites de
suite
voilà et derrière il a aligné mais alors
comme d'habitude mais alors si son truc
à elle c'est elle est incroyable mais
tournant et démarre avec des défaites et
laure derrière la ligne
il a massacré à nantes avec les doigts
ouais pas mal ouais c'est pas mal
donc il a battu qu'avec les noirs aussi
alors que keynes qui devait juste faire
nul pour être premier m comme ce qui
joue solide pas évident d'aller les
battre avec thé noir mais bon c'est
topalov injouable une dernière photo et
peut-être qu'on peut montrer encore de
topalov encore face à macro ici toujours
à sofia est probablement la même partie
d'ailleurs avec pau dont mario je suis
l'air comme ce qui à droite totalement à
droite
voilà donc même s'il elle master voilà
donc fait ce qu'il te pas le numéro un
mondial sur la liste avec plus de 2800
lots c'est un des rares joueurs à avoir
un sesto maria qui comme joueur ya là
kasparov évidemment qui a passé lundi
une 2853 même nom de 1840 au moins vous
êtes peut-être mais 850 sa part et est
ce que honda passé de 1800 je passe ici
une fois gna gna parler pendant trois
ans classement de juin donc ils sont que
trois
topalov électronique aussi cramique à
passer dès 1800 et il est redescendu en
dessous il est passé une fois là bas ils
sont en garde à travers l'art ils sont
quatre à avoir passé cette barre sachant
que fisher lui était placé à l'époque de
1785 qui est un record qui a tenu
presque transparent par stephan brousse
on sait que tu es un grand fan de
fischer née de là on va peut-être même
comme a été un peu nos parties du jour
voilà dans mes fonds pour dire que non
mais pour dire que quand tu as part of
et fait partie des grands en ayant passé
cette barre et quand on va on a deux
joueurs qui ont passé la barre dans
cette finale qui donne qui en donne
toute la légitimité ou 6 am helvètes
extraordinaire ça va être extraordinaire
suivre ce match
alors donc nous allons passer alors pas
tout de suite dans tout de suite
prochainement à une partie démonstration
de manière chronique maintenant besoin
d'eux est un top à l'origine topaloff
maintenant qu'on a vu une partie de
bonne humeur chronique et ce sera donc
une partie du monétarisme topalov contre
ruslan ponomariov qui a été champion du
monde fis des oui tout à fait qu'ils
aient 20 joueurs considérés comme très
très solide un genre très sérieux - beau
joueur qui est très technique en finale
qui est très très solide qui défend tous
qui contrôle tout qui joue très très
bien
donc voilà deux gros joueurs nous sommes
sur l'échiquier vesselin topalov contre
eux aux lames ponomariov et c'était au
master's aime-t-elle donc topalov
déjouer 2,4 dans cette partie alors que
bon il gagne aussi en cours des quatre
hommes ont commandé 10 peut jouer
n'importe qu'elle découpe une telle
master de sofia à nous tourner de parler
c'est le loto reine sofia
nous allons passer assez vite sur
l'ouverture qui est une ouverture
espagnol le couffo baisse caractérisée
par ce coup là voilà donc ça on a déjà
commenté dans de nombreuses émissions à
6 le fou se retire on veut pas donner la
paire de fou on peut on peut alors si on
peu près en beauce et des astuces double
nature on peut jouer aussi fou prend
qu'il bénisse et 6 voilà mais ça donne
la paire de fouet à une position
équilibrée longatte un petit avantage
pour les blancs surtout manny pacquio
quel point ça peut pas gagner astuces à
cause d'une astuce vous pouvez découvrir
le petit problème pour vous chez vous
faut c'est essayer de prendre le pion
aux cinq tours 1 en défense sur l'a4
tout ça est connue très collé 5
de 3,7 et joué des centaines de noms et
mots là il faut attaquer le fou tout est
ici sur le coût principal pendant des
années été ces trois l'on arrête avec
l'idée des quatre en arrêter ça parce
que l'ours et adams c'est ça c'est
adamski c3 qui a remis au goût du jour
le fameux gambie marshall dans
l'histoire était que marshall grand
ennemi de capable en cas le troisième
champion du monde eh bien en fait avait
préparé pendant dix ans cette ouverture
nos fameux gambie marche le gambit
marshall ici c'est un gambit opérant
pions et ça se poursuit les prix sous
son prix sera voilà et au delà le pion
aux phocéens gagne le clan si bien des
changes et noir vont avoir attaqué morne
ça s'appelle le dandy marshall ça a été
joué dans ce face à capablanca qui avait
quand même réussi à gagner la partie il
marche elle devait l'avoir mauvaise
parce que ça faisait dix ans qu'ils le
gardent attendait il attendait de la csa
petit mois ratés
voilà pour la course nous voter ps
wallace et donc les grandes histoires de
cette ouverture qui a acquis depuis
n'était plus trop jouer et adams a
commencé à rejouer ça alors à la fin des
années 90 et depuis les blancs peuvent
plus gagner
maintenant c'est un essai d'une force et
n'a pas ces nuls face il ya plus de
victoires d'happy victoire en contre
jour plus étroits ont joué ce qu'on
appelle des systèmes anti marché un
petit marché à trois on joue ça en
décale fou bessette detroit on est con
vous allez riac l'on peut plus jouer ses
trois des quatre semaines c'était pareil
c'est un peu plus passif des six alors
le plan des blancs quel est des deux f1
j'ai 3 c3 peut-être des 4 et peut-être
l'attaqué avec lequel et qui vient en
décembre ça c'est du super classique
non cet espagnol il commence par à 4
verrines topaloff ça c'est pour
affaiblir le tueur b5 éventuellement
lequel il peut passer par ces trois ont
la particularité d'être le disque ou pas
non quand même jusqu'à 10 ou même plus
y'a pas depuis ses champions oui très
peu des changes
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre nous avons pas
de manière très peu de contacts quel mal
ya 5-6 pas une partie de contact en
chalosse ne donne jamais c'est fou ça
permet pas au quinze de france fou à 2 c
5 les noirs contrôle le centre pointe de
l'espace mais en contre partie d'entre
elles a fait un très joli fou bien placé
il y avait des bd 2 il y basque et aux
play-offs qui est 17 ce qui est bien
avec topalov c'est que y voit de très
loin où il veut mettre sa pièce et finit
toujours par y arriver
tf1 il y va kébé 6 maintenant une petite
astuce d'actifs on voit que la menace
est quand même assez désagréable qui a
défendu un cadre donc fou des deux
maintenant sur qui les prend à 4 est une
possibilité on joue simplement b3 ok
peut pas revenu en b 6 puisque le
cabinet à 5 serait sans protection et
après b3 si on joue km et 2 qu'est la
dernière case désigné et bien c'est très
simple il est enfermé s'est enfermé un
peu de cases des buts
plus sévère nos coûts qu'il faut éviter
donc vous des deux attaques le camélia 5
et défend un direct quand on va trop
loin quand il faut bien calculé son coup
à foix sur deux soit elle va surtout
quand on a un cavalier qui arrive tout
seul on est bien séparer de tout le
reste des pièces c'est pas très bon en
général facile à prendre
des quatre normales c3 il faut casser un
peu ces pions là et en même temps ça
permet de défendre tu as un cadre avec
la dame qui ont français 3 français 3 ça
c'est bien joué vous pensez trois ont la
reprise normale et éduction mais ça
posait des problèmes exception et qu'ils
pouvaient être attaqués parfois ces six
donc ici la tâte lequel on dit qu'elle
et ses six maintenant stéphane que
veulent faire les blancs mais c'est la
question c'est la question est bien sans
doute ouvert le centre pour libérer leur
père de fou ou s'ils peuvent mais ils
semblent pas comment on voit pas comment
ça va être dur de jouer des quatre mais
n'en veulent attaquer ils veulent faire
jouer leurs deux fous voilà c'est ça
donc ils veulent préparer ils veulent
casser ce point là ils veulent préparer
les quatre d'accord
voilà ce qui est terrible c'est qu'on
aura le centre éventuellement la colonne
f et donc on y va donc à saintes
contre-pied d'accord qu'elle a dit aux 3
il est pas tout à fait presser encore
topalov mais il menace d'installer
câblée kasparov ou alors qui va dire des
5 km et 8 à 7
donc là il a vu un plan ponomariov il
veut les prendre ce fou c3 mais qui
parce qu'il pressent déjà que vous
travaillez kerviel 5-fu s'est vite et
maintenant c'est de là qu'elle a aidé 2
et en prépare l'avancé s44 avec le
réveil des deux fronts possibles
le cavalier en plus il peut revenir se
placer sur la case v6 où il peut revenir
se placer comme ça donc toutes les
pièces de topalov sont bien bien bien
dans la partie
c'est l'heure de f4 taille et ouverture
en fait dans cette partie on va assister
dans l'est qui viennent à la plus grande
aux mines et zombies et je n'ai vu un
fou province a un qui prend
oprean d'accord on a line est un
attaquant il était menaçant ce cavalier
alain cavayé 5 toujours
sinon on a trop peur faire le point f4
on l'a vu tout à l'heure on l'a vu avec
la partie kramnik dame g4 menace subtil
trop menaçant d'un projet cette plainte
puisse assez soutenue par le fou ici
c'est très fort
à noter que fou et 6 ici est jouable
mais alors je crois qu'on peut jouer fou
prend fut suivie de cavaliers aux quatre
avec attac champion des six attaques
sont une offre des possibilités du web
mais sinon j'ai vécu de l'intérieur de
salaire même salaire gagnant on voit pas
trop comment c'était plutôt fort en
cavalier des quatre ça a l'air très très
fort effectivement 21 interceptions du
fou oui et maintenant topalov alors même
pas ils pensent je pense à une
conception samaras basata mais trop bien
placé à la bêta vis-à-vis du c'est
évident donc cavalier ou quatre on y va
pour l'instant pas de menace ne le
dirais ça qu'il a pas de menace directe
non mais on est tranquille cavaliers à
b5 haye veuillez donc ils rapatrient un
peu un cavalier qui jouait pas il veut
prendre là à noter que la fourchette qui
est toujours possible
oui mais c'est pas grave total official
très calme sous des deux est alors c'est
là que commence justement cette fameuse
combinaison qui est complètement
spectaculaire qui est très très
difficile explique c'est à dire que
l'alors en fait s'en fout été bloqué par
la cave et d4 et maintenant ils te voilà
il est bloqué ici parce que les bouchers
donc en fait il est en train de se
redéployer
il veut il veut prendre le pion f4 avec
le fou de façon après que ce fut sans
doute haye sur la case h6 tout à fait
pour menaces et mat
tout à fait c'est une des idées il veut
rapatrier s'en fout ici puisque le fou
n'avait plus assez d'activités sur
intégral qui était donc là il compte
même plus matérielles à ce niveau là en
fout des deux donc évidemment maintenant
que fou n'est plus là et pas de problème
qui a laissé 2 c'est l'heure de la
fourchette fourchette fork donc on peut
le voir ce que les attaques les deux
tours des deux tours donc l'une des deux
va tomber
ça c'est un cavalier mais bon on qualité
quand on est en attaque c'est pas très
grave
ouais mais tout à fait fou prend 1,4 bon
alors quand il ya du flou artistique
matin sinon parce que là maintenant et
loire c'est énorme
mines qui peut y avoir dans cette
position parce qu'on a le fou à ne faut
pas l'oublier ce jurassien il est très
très fort et il est toujours là
il est très très fort il vient ici boom
sur le pion excellent qui peut pas
bouger on peut menacer à tout moment f 5
et 6 avec menace d'un projet sept
matches oui on peut menacer fois ci ce
voile avec menace toujours d'un point et
ce cavalier leucate qui est énorme
protège des cases quand même 6 par
exemple et peut éventuellement bondir
angers 5 dans certaines dans certaines
variantes mais alors c'est ce qui est
très très bon stéphane 51.1 francs les
blancs n'ont pas vraiment menace directe
oui mon fai s'amoncellent bah ça se
précise
c'est pas ça ne va pas salon pour
l'instant on donne des qualités là qu'on
va perdre le pion à 5 au 6 e étage avec
le bon ça fait beaucoup c'est vrai elle
roi à schwyz
il s'est dit un petit coup prévenir pour
aider les mets parfois de se dire je
suis pas pressé de prendre le tour de
toute façon ça c'est vrai on l'est
puisque pour l'instant que ce soit il
veut éviter et doit peut-être tout
simplement aussi que les des blancs
jouent le coup tours 3
vous montrez corps aux trois entités
femme malheureuse voilà quand quelqu'un
ça qui prend pas oui c'est ça parce que
s'ils prenaient une des tours
peut-être ce coup devient possible et
c'est tout ensuite coulisses peut-être
en g3 oui avec alors là une grosse
possibilité d'attaquer beaucoup de métal
sur le roi je sais pas si c'était l'idée
mais en tout cas c'était impossible
cette possibilité en tout cas l'ajout
d'un match terne topalov toujours assez
obscur mais il finit par faire craquer
gagne la sopref cette menace au prince
est un faux problème c'est ici quelques
jours et ensuite s'il revient du cisme
nasma très difficile à paris voire même
par rapport à mai donc faut prendre
cette force serait ponama à jouer
pourquoi on fait donc la qualité serait
récupéré après français attention oui
cavaliers protos et de la haye oui on
prend
oui dame prend à cinq attaques la tour
avec échec un peu fou à et le fou alors
là que faire ça à l'air très grave
c'est très grave tour 1 où on se met
dans un clouage lui même c'est vrai que
là bas tout un peuple et même et le
fonds continue à contrôler des cases le
four il a banni la russie a pas perdre
de place mylène qui a été moins pour
l'instant mais c'est vrai c'est en fait
et bien c'est presque terminé déjà
tourbe et des beats et c'est là que la
combinaison est incroyable mais c'est là
alors je ne sais pas comment il ya pensé
non je ne sais pas ce qu'ils faisaient
attention attention à leur jeu
c'est quand même c'est que tout à
l'heure la tante quand la dame était
encore en 18 pour montrer oui quand la
dame était encore en est vite parce
qu'elle allait la traiter
elle était comme cette dame elle est pas
très loin d'hama prend à sec c'est bon
tu apprends à 5
oui ça on peut le montrer je veux dire
que la dame défendez les cas elle qu
elle défend les quinze mois avec
téléphone les 15 et l'aller quand même
partis à la chasse
et qui dit qui va à la chasse perd sa
place à sa place effectivement les
caisses dans son mondial voilà
exactement mais stéphane très
impressionnant ici
la combinaison topaloff comment alors je
sais pas comment il y as pensé mais
alors il a vu un truc incroyable
il a vu qu'il allait mattei semble avoir
toujours après sa mort vers la chasse
perd sa place comment faire pour aller
prendre son courage 7 et bien vous allez
voir tout de suite et six pions prend
1,6
hélas le coup d'une finesse
spectaculaire rouages de alors on
comprend toujours pas comment il attaqué
non mais ce qu'on comprend quand on joue
en h2 et loi c'est qu'on peut libérer x
2 oui ça menace inquiète échec
ces menaces font progresser ça peut
menacer faut qu'on accepte puisque sur
dame 30% et celle qu'on peut encore
jouer derrière
imaginons par exemple le coup tour 17
voilà un coup comme ça il y aurait fort
en attaque la dame avec la cour
oui alors il faut prendre la tour ça
sans doute non par an prochain je me
suis trompé en fait il faut aussi ça
infosys ont compris pour éviter pour les
plus forts voilà il faut et 5 et la
menace mater seimat la cemac puisque
dame prend 1,7 est apparemment lassé
version des trucs en fait on n'a pas
peur de perdre la tour au contraire on
s'en sert pour attaquer la dame et
gagner un temps évidemment et puis si
les noirs prennent le fou il comprend la
logique intervention de deux ponots
marriott qui bloque le fou wade a
compris que ce fou de mener trop fort
mais ici qu'avec les points 6 classes
d'un proche est mat manas match fou pour
26 des 4 et maintenant ça y est c'est
l'idéal un fou mais un est imparable
qu'est ce que c'est beau ici après dun
prend à 5 pour un boulet que il faut
imaginer que dans trois coups les trois
pions ont disparu ah oui mais tu es fou
b12 lasse pas d'en acheter qu'à un point
c'est vraiment incroyable on va revoir
les intenses mais courage 2,97 des cinq
cavaliers francis on libère vous prend d
4d cap et ça y est le coup incroyable
1 le coup donc là on imagine les dames 3
2 il n'y a pas d'autres imaginent
cervelle et prend des quatre caves et
prend des quatre fous des noms ou bien
attaque la dame attaque la dame en plus
des menaces maths et menacent pas non
plus imparable ce matin peut pas parce
que lecavalier a que lecavalier qui peut
s'interposer mais ce prix sacrifiés
s'agit les prix par le fou et il ya
maintenant beaucoup trop cher
les maths quand même de toute façon
voilà donc ici donc obligatoire dans
cette position après des cadres d'un
franc fois de plus fou c'était bientôt
reprend on va regarder la suite de la
partie qui maintenant vont il ya quand
reste comme compliqué d'y aller j'ai un
avantage blanc au niveau matériel
puisqu'il ya dame contrôle au tour ce
qui est à peu près équivalent non alors
il faut pas faire ça comme ça ses fans
pour contre tours fou contrefout dames
contre tours étaient valides et d'un
contre ou non plus voir conserver sur
damas contre cavaliers ce qui est un
petit avantage objectivement mais pas
forcément gagnant encore vous sauterez
sans travailler quoi maintenant
un autre du travail ou pas l'offre va
nous montrer une technique exemplaire p4
et déstabilise alors qu'est venu aussi
fou aux 5
ainsi ça qui brûlait c'était sûr
surprise damman sur la grille 4 on avait
l'idée de gagner tout de suite faux sec
attaque le fou si on prend d'un cran
avec échec lengagne cavaliers et là ça
fait d'armes contre cure et d'assez
gagnons donc qui va de 6 pouces un bon
échange des fous oui on prend ces 55
pour ses mythes vous décidiez son
protège le font pour des huit mois c'est
donc là c'est là c'est à la fin de
partie on peut dérouler oui en
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on fait parce que
voilà ici c'est c'était qu'on va
commenter brièvement c'était mais grosso
modo les noirs n'ont plus la même façon
la vendetta se plaint la tâche blanc est
clair il ya eu des questions ses cinq
campus qui traîne voilà 17 d'apprendre
des 5
voilà maintenant on a pris la fuite on a
tous pris la 9 3 on va voir voilà on a
pris déjà tous les pions qui traînait
dans cédé 8 donc ici ça pose plus de
problème particulier il faut changer les
airs de tout retour à lyon en échange
d'une paire de course à la taille et à
pousser les pions h et pour les créer
des menaces de maths au tour du roi crée
des menaces de maths en plus il faut
protéger ceux qui ont des six ans
heureusement qu'il est là bas cinq
langues et cissé avait aucune chance de
gagner dans l'attentât fait mais il fait
diversion est toujours au bon moment
donc la fin de partie rapide
moi j'essaie d'amener quatre échecs
roger 8 d'un v6 rassurant le pion à 6
étant prises là il y avait une petite
astuce pour le fun et là haut c'est très
joli puisque surtout prend dame qui on
prend tour c'est ça et on peut pas
empêcher le pion de fer d'hamsik l'a6
les classiques quand un cavalier est à
côté comme ça
le pion fait toujours dames avec
l'option peut pas les voilà tous demos
est bon c'est gadget parce que ça ça
n'apporte rien à la position enfants et
sept ont gagné dans 17 c'est bon là
c'est fini puisque dame contre eux pour
ça gagne on peut
oui il ya des pressions il ya des cats
forteresse par exemple ils étaient six
en échange les pions h
oui les petites chances de nul donc en
faut-il jouer précis encore mais ici le
problème c'est que quand on va monter le
roy on va menacer de donner la dame
contre la tour des finales d'options
voilà c'est ça c'est bien ça c'est ce
qui va se passer a fait échec
voilà pourquoi ben voila et lavelanet
l'adoption il ya peut-être on peut la
revoir rapidement vous la montrer pour
comprendre enfin ce jour-là - il parlé
c'est un autre coup trois mois et c'est
bien sûr on va se mettre sur les cases
dit critique pour le 3g vie est brève 6
watts castanet cette scène originale
ouais ouais je suis le roi
moi j'ai signé ici moi j'évite on prend
le pion il adoption comptes rendra sa
galerie voilà on a cassé à n'importe
quelle leçon disponible sur des oiseaux
la leçon pour vérifier sa super party
peu près très belle partie de l'offre
mais également très bonne partie de la
nuit ouais mais là oui tout un art que
leur suivi cette histoire de libérer
trois questions que c'est joli faut le
voir c'est très très original n'avait-on
pas l'offre et d'une créativité
incroyable vraiment très très loin s'en
faut du sang-froid aussi parce qu'il
passe quand même par une position où
l'ordinateur d'excès perdant pendant dix
coups de suite
donc je pense que c'est humainement pas
calculable
je sais c'est pas possible si elle n'a
pas plu tout calculer il s'est fié à son
intuition
oui il a une âme situation d'addiction
en partie bien sûr donc championnat du
monde
trawick topalov sur les gones à toutes
les émissions toutes les parties
instrumentales nantes est disponible le
temps le temps de les mettre en ligne
mais assez vite en fait et
donc on vous donne rendez vous
évidemment sur le site officiel de
diagonale tv.com et aussi sur échec la
délicat demi point com pour suivre aussi
les cours de jean luc chavanon à très
bientôt sur ces mots fidèles et
inscrivez vous sur des bonal tv.com dans
la newsletter diagonale pour avoir
toutes les infos sur la sortie des
émissions à bientôt